[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when we think about trash we often don't
imagine the garments that we wear but
when we're done with them they also end
up in landfills just like the trash that
we throw out every day the fashion
industry is the second top waste
producing industry in the world our
trend cycle moves extremely quickly
which encourages consumers to purchase
and dispose at a rapid rate but that
leads to a lot of damage to our
environment from the waste produced by
our garments the MIT trash and Show is
an annual fashion show put on the mi
t--'s undergraduate associations
Committee on sustainability and every
year we invite designers from all over
the Boston community to design garments
out of unconventional or upcycle
materials and then have them shown at
our Fashion Show the show started 11
years ago and we've come a long way
since then but the trashing shows a main
goal remains the same as it did when it
started which is to promote awareness
about the waste that the fashion
industry produces and spark conversation
about where our clothes come from how
they were made and where they go once
we're done with them designers are
encouraged to use trash or recycled
materials or materials that would
otherwise be thrown away in order to
create pieces that can be worn so past
materials have included newspapers soda
boxes soda cans electrical wires and
things like that clothing is usually
very flowy it's very organic and needs
to mold to the shape of a human body
so working around those material
properties can be difficult
typically the designer that wants to
participate is someone that wants to
tackle a challenge they come from all
majors and all backgrounds but
ultimately they're looking for a
creative outlet it's not very easy to
create a garment out of trash and it
takes a lot of time so these people are
driven by risk-taking and they want to
make a product that otherwise wouldn't
exist the trashing show actually takes a
lot of work to organize you need to have
a V you need to talk to facilities book
a venue and then also keep track of all
the models and designers who are
participating in the show often people
are just really amazed to see a product
that they had just thrown away worn on
someone's body and worn in a way that
like is a functional garment that's
something that people don't usually get
to see around campus when it comes to
judging we have a panel of three judges
all related to sustainability but also
coming from different disciplines we
provide them a set of criteria that
involves whether an outfit is
sustainable how much recycled material
it uses how aesthetically it works and
the technical fabrication skills of the
piece
so we give out a few different awards at
the show first second and third and
audience choice but also other
committees on the undergraduate
Association committee for sustainability
give out prizes based off of what they
do so there's a lot of different
opportunities to celebrate the different
aspects of pieces that designers create
when people think of MIT they usually
don't think of fashion but in fact a lot
of students here are very interested in
fashion or just creating art and
something really special about MIT is
that kids have a wide array of interests
and it may be a fashion isn't one of
them the trashin show encourages them to
try something new and MIT kids always
love trying something new and pushing
their boundaries and creating clothes
out of trash is a challenge and it takes
engineering and design and technology
which are all things that students here
are very interested in
[Music]
you